a trailer for the final season of Game
of Thrones is out and it shows that the
start of season 8 is a lot like the
start of season 1 with a queen and a
king coming to Winterfell but this time
the queen is Daenerys and the king is
Jon Snow
Daenerys brings her army of unsullied
and a boy watches from above just like
how brand watch from above in episode 1
Daenerys also brings her dragons the
first dragons of Winterfell in over a
hundred years there's a lot of magic and
symbolism in these creatures of fire
flying above this icy fortress Sansa
Stark has never seen dragons and magic
before most of her story has been in the
south with the political plots so if she
was uncomfortable last season with
psychic bran and faceless ayah if Season
eight is all about fantastical magical
battles how will Sansa and her skills
fit in and censor has enjoyed ruling
Winterfell will Queen Daenerys threaten
her power
ayuh also sees her first dragon and
she's excited she's always wanted
adventure and freedom and power and
that's what dragons represent aya is a
fan of visenya targaryen Dragon Queen
from hundreds of years ago so maybe IO
will also like Daenerys this new Dragon
Queen we see John and Daenerys with the
Dragons Rhaegar and drogon regal is the
green one and dragon is the red one
Daenerys rides dragon it's named after
her first husband Drogo and regal is
named after Rhaegar Targaryen Daenerys
is brother and John's real father
so maybe John will ride Rago there could
be a cute montage of Daenerys teaching
John to ride oh wait we already saw that
though the Dragons have a bunch of
blackened bones which was probably their
breakfast but we heard last season that
Winterfell doesn't have enough food for
its people so will they be able to feed
two giant dragons if the dragons get too
hungry they might start eating people
which was a problem in Mereen Daenerys
used to have three dragons but Viserion
was killed and taken by the night king
can dragon and regal defeat their undead
sibling John stands in the Winterfell
godswood this is where Ned Stark came to
pray and contemplate John thinks that
Ned is his father but last season bran
and Sam learned the truth that John is
the son of Rhaegar and Lyanna Sam plans
to tell John about his parents and he
looks worried about it because the truth
will make John and Danny's relationship
a lot more complicated for one thing it
means that Daenerys is John's aunt and
they both sext but also Daenerys is
identity is built on her being the last
Targaryen heir to the throne if John is
the true heir ahead of Daenerys what has
Dany been fighting for all this time it
also raises questions about John's
identity is he a stock or a Targaryen a
bastard or a king it looks like John and
Danny have a dnm in the Winterfell
crypts possibly by the statue of John's
real mother lianna this again parallels
episode 1 when Ned and Robert discuss
Leanna in the crypts we also see Tyrion
who was very concerned last season about
John and Danny's relationship how will
he react to John's true parentage and
whose side is Tyrion really on there
might not be much time to angst over
incest because the White Walkers are
coming to attack Winterfell Jaime
Lannister arrives and says he'll help
fight for the living last season Jaime
promised to help find the White Walkers
and now he wants to keep that pledge
Jaime has always been hated as an
Oathbreaker and Kingslayer
this war is Jaime's chance at redemption
and he's got a lot of crimes to redeem
last time he was at Winterfell Jaime
crippled bran Jaime fought against Ned
and Ward against Robb will the Starks
make alliance with their enemy probably
because as John says everyone alive is
on the same side now fighting against
the dead so everyone prepares for battle
at Winterfell we say Davos on the walls
even though he isn't much of a fighter
we say Aird torment and barrack it
looked like barrack and torment my dad
died last season when the war
but they've survived to fight again Edie
became Lord Commander of the Nights
Watch when John left so he must have run
south when the wall fell but how much of
the Nights Watch survived that was an
eight thousand year old institution is
that gone maybe with the White Walkers
coming everyone his knights watch now we
see Gendry with a big pile of
dragonglass mind from dragon star gander
you'll need to make a bunch of weapons
to fight the dead but hopefully they'll
also be time for him to reunite with his
friend aya we say Jorah and the Dothraki
Jorah has the sword heart's pain misses
the Valyrian sword of house Tarly that
Sam took from his dad but Sam isn't good
with a sword so it makes sense that he'd
give hot Spain too Jorah they made
friends last season when sam ciurdar of
gray scale we see Brienne and Podrick
with the Knights of the Vale these guys
only came north to help fight the
Bolton's they never signed up for this
Walking Dead [ __ ] but everyone's coming
together to help fight the dead we see
grey worm kiss Masson die while John's
voiceover says that the White Walkers
don't feel this is a reminder of why
everyone's fighting this war isn't for a
lord or a throne this is about the
survival of life and love itself against
the cold dead enemy grey worm looks
intense as he prepares for battle the
unsullied were bred to be emotionless
but with Masson die grey worm has found
something worth fighting for
there are trebuchet and the unsullied
maybe to throw fire at the dead while
the warriors prepare for battle we see
women and children and Varys in the
crypts this is like in the battle for
Helm's Deep in Lord of the Rings Game of
Thrones director said he studied that
battle for this episode Varys looks
scared and out of place when he used to
be so confident and powerful among the
politics of King's Landing
how can Varys stay relevant in this
magical apocalyptic finale we should at
least get some good conversations here
during the battle it could be like in
the red cape during the Battle of the
Blackwater in the background we can see
Gilly and her baby remember that this
baby was originally meant to be
sacrificed to the white walk
and when Gilly took the baby South
instead the walkers came after him it's
possible that the walkers still want
gillies baby it's also possible that the
dead might rise from these crypts there
are hints in the books about ancient
Starks with white Walker blood go watch
that video the battle for Winterfell
begins Brienne and Jaime fight the dead
on the walls Brienne wields the Valyrian
sword Oathkeeper while Jamie uses
widow's wail both of these swords were
made from the Starks sword ice so the
reunion of Brienne and Jaime has all
sorts of symbolic weight to it this is
also kind of like a dream Jaime has in
the books where he and Brienne wield
flaming swords and face the dead amidst
darkness and doom this connects to the
prophecy of azor Ahai and Nissa Nissa
and could mean the deaths of Jaime and
Brienne we see the Hound amidst fire and
the Hound is afraid of fire because when
he was young his brother the mountain
burned his face fire is why the Hound
ran from battle in season two and was
afraid of barek in season 3 maybe now
the Hound will face his fear to defeat
the dead who horned him both
metaphorically and literally because
it's hinted that the Hound will face the
mountain in a fight called cleganebowl
since the mountain is Undead the Hound
might need fire to defeat him we also
see Jon running and doing something
heroic in the books he also has a dream
of fighting the dead with fire we see
horses running across snow and it looks
like there might be some wolves in there
as well we might see John's direwolf
ghost or even the wolf pack led by ayahs
dire wolf
Nymeria and we see aya doing some sick
spin moves with a stick like the
faceless men trained her or maybe it's a
dragon glass spear to kill the dead but
a victim here has a lot of blood
zombies don't usually bleed that much
remember that the White Walkers can also
raise animals like polar bears and there
are stories of giant ice spiders the
night is dark and full of terrors and
aya might face them aya says I know dear
he's got many faces I look forward to
seeing this one because remember the
faceless men taught aya about the
many-faced God a name for death the
night King later of the White Walkers is
an embodiment of death
he's like a symbol of the people I is
killed and maybe of her own death aya
takes a dragonglass dagger to kill White
Walkers but it looks like things go
badly for her because the trailer starts
with aya looking scared and hurt in the
dark she's got a wound on her head and
she's running in terror when was the
last time aya seemed so scared
it looks like aya is running from
zombies but why is she so afraid if
she's got a dragonglass dagger and
valyrian blade maybe those zombies were
people she knew maybe they're dead
Starks risen from the crypts like a
mother or her brother one way or another
it looks like death is catching up with
aya in book 1 John jokes that aya will
die in the winter that they'll find her
body with a needle locked tight between
her fingers so at Winterfell almost
every character is desperately fighting
for the survival of all life but down in
King's Landing Cersei is scheming to
save herself
she's got a shiny new outfit looking
smug and powerful and she's with her two
best friends the creepy mad scientist
Qyburn and the zombie Mountain almost
everyone else has died or abandoned her
including her lover Jaime last season
Cersei sent euron greyjoy to buy a
mercenary group called the golden
company and here there are neurons ships
with their leader homeless hairy
strickland
the golden company is said to be the
most powerful army in air sauce with
20,000 men horses and elephants so we're
finally gonna get some Molly font action
in Game of Thrones in the books the
golden company has a complex plotline
involving the black fires and a kid
called young Griff none of that seems to
be happening in the show the company is
just here to help Cersei cling to the
throne until the bitter end this looks
like strickland standing before Cersei
on the throne with the mountain and
Qyburn but this character is unclear
maybe
Iran or the banker tie CONUS Taurus or
even Sansa with the red hair it's hard
to tell in this shot says he looks more
vulnerable
she's got sort of a smile but also tears
in her eyes she is drinking wine which
is weird cuz last season so she said she
was pregnant
maybe Cersei loses her unborn child and
with nothing left to protect
she'll unleash her full fury upon
Westeros and there's also this weird
shot maybe it's John at Winterfell
or maybe it's Arya in King's Landing
that could be a brazier in the Great
Hall it looks like she's holding a bow
and we know I can use a bow so maybe
this shot is are you trying to kill
Cersei like she said she would last
season will aya succeed and kill the
Queen there are rumors that this will be
the only trailer for season eight so
this might be the last ever trailer for
Game of Thrones we're gonna make the
most of the final season so make sure
you subscribe and click the bell
analyzing a new Game of Thrones trailer
is like solving a puzzle you go to find
connections between bits of information
to find an explanation that makes sense
if you like puzzles you might like the
new daily problems on brilliant teaching
math science engineering and computer
science each daily problem explores a
concept like the cosmic microwave
background or how to slice a doughnut
then it gives you a problem that you can
solve with that information if you need
help with a problem there are other
users discussing this solution so next
time you go to spare five minutes you
can learn something new and get a little
smarter each day sign up for free at
brilliant org slash alt shift X and the
first two hundred to sign up can get 20%
off an annual premium subscription to
unlock the archive of daily problems and
dozens of courses on maths science space
doughnuts and beyond thanks for watching
and thanks to the patrons including
Matthew Unger Emily N and O Jason Rankin
Ashley Smith andreas Constantine rodas
Arnold Brandon butchaiah and Steven
plasencia sheis
you